does playing and stretched really make
you better at cs go
does he see him does he see him four by
three four by three
are the paddles on your scuff controller
really helping you
it's always been my controller of choice
is your fight stick making you
worse at street fighter i'm thinking
about learning a fight stick
is it worth it is the g pro really all
that's cracked up to me
i can't use any other mouse besides the
g pro and is aim assist
actually just cheating i don't think
mouse and keyboard vs controllers should
ever be a thing that's competing for
money
we've got a brand new show from the
score esports that's about
technology and games but not like the
precise number of frames you'll get out
of your rtx 3090
if you could even get your hands on one
we want to answer
your questions about the intersection
between esports
and the [ __ ] you use to play them
because after work we're just like you
we're sitting around playing ballerin or
siege
or god forbid league of legends and the
second you go on youtube you will find
an in-depth review of any mouse or
keyboard or headset out there
but sometimes you just want an answer to
the one question that matters
what do i need to make me better
at the games i love can't kaiser get any
more
there's three guys
[Music]
dumping one it's well on onto thief i
said this the first time i called tens
this is his world and we're just living
in it get up attack
that's it oh my god lizzy defeating the
two top players
in the world right now cooling well
above his years clearing cars
this show will feature insight from
everyone from pros
to professors giving you the science
and stories behind the sickest products
weirdest setups and the age-old
assumptions that we've all just
taken for granted this is the story of
meets
mice and keyboards this is cracked
you